on the first day of Christmas and gare
said to me the recipe for madam better
meat on the second day of Christmas
Edgar sent to me to leave your batteries
and the recipe for madam better mean on
the third day of Christmas and you're
sent to me three litres of acetone two
lithium batteries and the recipe for
methamphetamine on the fourth day of
Christmas Edgar sent to me four counts
of hydrochloric acid three litres of
acetone to lithium batteries and the
recipe for methamphetamine on the fifth
day of Christmas and you're sent to me
five top top fingers for cancer
hydrochloric acid three layers of
acetone two lithium batteries and the
recipe for madam batter me on the sixth
day of Christmas and you're sent to me
six chicken buckets five chopped off
fingers for cancer hydrochloric acid
three layers of acetone - lithium
batteries and the recipe for madam
better mean on the seventh day of
Christmas
and you're sent to me seven branding
cash six chicken buckets five chopped
off fingers for cancer fighter Cory cat
said three layers of acetone to leave in
batteries and the recipe for madam pet
amine on the eighth day of Christmas
Edgar sent to me eight picks on my mom
seven grand in cash six chicken buckets
five chopped off fingers four cans vitae
chloric acid three layers of acetone two
lithium batteries and the recipe for
Madame better mean on the ninth day of
Christmas and you're sent to me nine
Mexicans and coats eight pics of my mom
seven grand in cash six chicken buckets
pie topped our fingers pork and some
hydrochloric acid three layers of
acetone two lithium batteries and the
recipe for Madame better mean on the
tenth day of Christmas and you're sent
to me ten dead prostitutes nine Mexicans
and coats eight pics of my mom seven
branding cash six chicken buckets five
chopped our fingers for cats of
hydrochloric acid three liters of
acetone two lithium batteries
and the recipe for methamphetamine on
the eleventh day of Christmas and you're
sent to me eleven cops shooting ten dead
prostitutes nine Mexicans and coats
eight picks my mom seven grand in cash
six chicken buckets five chopped off
fingers for cat's body carcass 8 3
liters of acetone two lithium batteries
and the recipe for madame feta mean on
the twelfth day of christmas edgar sent
to me he made me a speech and now he
calls me Jesse
how's it going bros spambot hope you
bros enjoyed that christmas special it
was made by cypher den she did an
amazing job so go check out our channel
i'll leave a link here go subscribe and
tell her I sent you
Bros have a great Christmas if you don't
celebrate Christmas have a happy
holidays or happy whatever you'll be
doing thank you so much for this amazing
year and I want to thank you all for for
being there here's a brofist for many
more brush stay awesome